you know there's a lot that could be
taken from this Epstein thing a lot of
angles to explore a lot of lessons to be
learned but here's one right from the
top I think and this maybe is the main
lesson this is what we all can take from
it and that is and that is don't be a
scumbag you know don't be a scumbag look
look at the reaction to Epstein's death
I mean the guy died
they gave however he died it was it was
apparently somewhat gruesome and how has
the world reacted to that mockery
derision anger just because not because
it's not not now because we're sad that
he's dead but because he didn't suffer
enough and he didn't get to testify
against his against his friends
certainly no sadness no mourning of any
kind no respect even and for good reason
don't take this the wrong way I'm not
sitting here saying that we should be
more respectful of the pedophile sex
offender because he's dead now in fact
the whole idea that you know we should
have respect for a nun respectable
person just because they happen to die
to me has never made a lot of sense he's
getting exactly the reaction he deserves
but that shows you something doesn't it
shows you ie lived his life with no
concern for basic human dignity
he had his sick twisted fun in in
whatever way he wanted to have it and
all of that went away in the blink of an
eye and now he's a cold lifeless corpse
that was found on the floor of a jail
cell and the whole world now is spitting
on his grave and for as long as he is
remembered at all he will be remembered
only as a profoundly evil degenerate
dirtbag and that's all his legacy is
going to be and the most significant
thing about his life is going to be his
death only because we're trying to
figure out how it happened that's it
the futility of evil doesn't it this guy
had his glamorous private islands and
his his Jets and all of that kind of
stuff but then all of that was gone an
instant and his body was just laying
there on the cold cement floor and
people spent the weekend making fun of
his suicide or apparent suicide with
internet memes it's just not worth it
I guess is what I'm trying to say being
evil is just not worth it in the end the
trade-off isn't worth it so I think
that's the first lesson don't be a
scumbag that's what we hopefully we can
all take from this is it G I you know
maybe I don't want to be a scumbag as it
turns out but there's a lot more to be
said and as we look at the latest on the
Epstein case and we try to figure out
what happened why it happened how it
happened what it all means and we'll get
into that in just a second but first you
know it's it's summer and we all know
what that means you've got flies &
insects invading your home like a like a
like an army take trying to take over
set up fort in your house and who knows
where all those insects and everything
were last and they are there now they're
crawling all over your counter and your
food who knows where they were before
that
that's how germs are spread that's how
diseases spread and that's why we'd like
to thank our sponsors over at dynatrap
dynatrap is the leading manufacturer of
outdoor mosquito and insect traps and
now they're coming inside they've got a
solution for indoor pests as well which
to me is the main place where I really
am worried about them because I'm a
shut-in I spend all my time inside
anyway so that's I need to make sure
that none of those outside creatures
make it in here
the dynatrap fly light is what you need
the dynatrap fly light works day and
night to attract and trap flies fruit
flies mosquitoes other pesky insects and
you know it really does work forget
those disgusting fly strips any of that
the primitive ways of dealing with
insects forget about that sign trap fly
light looks like a subtle nightlight
that plugs into any indoor outlet trust
me I've been using this thing the
dynatrap fly light for a while now and
it absolutely works so get yours at
dynatrap comm it's DUI in a tra p.com
enter the promo code Walsh and receive
15%
any of their products dynatrap the safe
silent simple solution to household
insect control okay so the latest in the
epstein case we know that he died on
Friday of course as you've heard
just hours after thousands of pages of
his case files were released to the
public files that implicates some of the
most powerful and richest people on
earth including apparently Prince
Andrews Prince Andrew I should say
Andrews Prince Andrews mentioned other
famous rich people not always by name
but hours after that he's dead and now
we're being told by the by the prison in
New York where he was kept that he was
taken off of suicide watch a few weeks
ago even though apparently he allegedly
tried to kill himself earlier last month
he was on suicide watch they took him
off of it and now we're told that
there's no video of the alleged suicide
conveniently because the camera wasn't
trained into his cell
they've got video maybe that shows the
comings and goings outside of the cell
but there's no video of the cell itself
and we're told that his cell mate - he
did have a cell mate apparently but his
cell mate was transferred out of his
cell hours before he died
for epstein died and we're told that
prison guards were supposed to check on
Epstein every 20 minutes but they hadn't
checked on him for several hours leading
up to his death it's a lot of
coincidences going on here you know
we've got the release of the documents
we've got he's taken off a suicide watch
inexplicably cell mate is transferred
out they don't check on him and now he's
dead and that's why and look I know that
we're being lectured by the media not to
engage in conspiracy theories there's
been a lot of that by the media say
AUB's your responsible irresponsible to
talk about conspiracy there there is
nothing crazy or irresponsible about
wondering whether the official narrative
is actually true especially because
there really is
official narrative yet I mean well the
official narrative I guess is that he
committed suicide but there's not a lot
there's not much else to it
we know that Epstein was a pimp to some
of the most powerful people on the
planet we know that okay that's not it's
not a theory we know that we know that
those people obviously whoever his
clientele consisted of these are people
who by definition were sex abusers and
child rapists and we also know that they
probably didn't want to be exposed as
such and we know we can assume anyway
that if you're willing to rape kids if
you're willing to fly around the world
with a sex trafficker and and molest and
abuse and rape children all across the
globe you probably will have no moral
compunction about killing a witness
especially when the witness is a scumbag
himself I mean compared to in really if
you're if you're one of these rich
wealthy child rapist you might as well
kill Epstein there are and it's yeah I
mean your ticket the hell's already
booked anyway what's what's the
difference considering all the other bad
things you've done so we know all that
so it's certainly not at all
unreasonable in the slightest bit
to think that they would want to off
this guy to keep them quiet
it just makes of course they would
powerful criminals kill or attempt to
kill witnesses all the time so the
people that are acting like this is some
guy who conspiracy there what do you
think witness protection is why do you
think that exists it's because if you're
gonna if you're gonna turn witness
against some high-ranking criminal of
some kind a mob boss for instance then
they might want to take you down so
you've got to be protected the people
that that Epstein was gallivanting
around with these people were far more
powerful than some mob boss in New
Jersey so this isn't that we're not
talking faked moon landings and lizard
people here okay this is a logical
thought process and I don't know you
know I don't know what happened to him
neither do you nobody does right now or
at least the people who do know aren't
saying so all I know is that a global
sex trafficker with rich and powerful
client
died in his cell under very mysterious
circumstances that's what I know
was it a conspiracy well it sure as hell
could have been now I will say this
though over the weekend folks on the
right spent their time blaming Bill
Clinton and the Hillary Clinton the
Clintons in general there was hashtag
Clinton body count was trending on
Twitter and then people on the Left were
blaming Trump and saying hashtag Trump
body count is just this back and forth
I'll say right now that you don't have
to be a fan of either of those people I
mean whether you don't to be Glenn fan
you don't have to be a Trump fan from a
purely nonpartisan perspective I find it
very difficult to believe that either of
them had anything to do with this and
here's why the Clintons are a joke now
so the people that's how your Clintons
are everywhere killing click killing
witnesses yo you almost give them too
much credit I'm not saying that they
wouldn't do that if they had the chance
but these are totally morally bankrupt
individuals of course but you you are
giving them way more power than they
actually have the Clintons right the
Clinton machine basically doesn't exist
anymore it's defunct and they just they
don't have a lot of power I mean who if
who's who's gonna listen to Bill Clinton
Bill Clinton comes along and says you
need to kill this guys why should I do
that
what are you gonna do what do you have
over me so I don't think Clinton has
that kind of power and Trump again you
know yeah if you're a Trump fan you're
gonna say ah he would never do that but
even if you're not a Trump fan Trump
hardly has control over his own White
House he can't stop the leaks and
everything coming from his own White
House so do you think he can you think
he'd be able to arrange something like
this
no in both cases there are people in
this world far far far richer and far
far far more powerful than either Trump
or Clinton and yeah I know the Trump is
president itíd States ostensibly
allegedly the most powerful person in
the world because of that but he's
really not and this is not again this
isn't that
you know we're not talking lizard people
here okay it's just it's it's a fact
that an American politician even the
president he's in office for four to
eight years eight years at most
then he's gone he's a politician he
doesn't have he doesn't rule over his
massive bureaucratic government with an
iron fist he can't control everything
that the government does there are
people in the world a lot more powerful
than that you know if you are I mean
Jeff Bezos the the Amazon guys worth
like a hundred billion dollars you know
too much power a hundred billion dollars
can buy you and I'm not implicating Jeff
Bezos here by the way I'm just an
example of a more powerful person and
and so I was some kind of conspiracy if
this was a hit carried out on a famous
inmate in federal prison if it was if it
was it could have been we don't know the
person responsible is probably a very
very very wealthy and very very powerful
person and it could quite likely be
someone who's who's you know so rich and
powerful you don't even know their name
you know not not like a celebrity we're
not talking celebrity rich and powerful
we're talking about above that and we'll
probably never know who they are and
that and that's the unfortunate reality
of the situation there they're probably
never gonna be held accountable for it
there is another possibility though of
course there's there's this conspiracy
possibility but there's there's more
than that and there's there's the other
there's the more boring possibility I
want to talk about that in a second but
before we go any further I want to thank
our friends at Boland branch you know
we're never gonna be able to agree on it
to agree on everything or really
anything as a society except for this
now we could all use more that sleep is
great first of all and we could all use
more of it getting a great night's sleep
is easier than ever thanks to the
world's softest sheets brought to you by
bowline branch everything bowline branch
makes from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton which
means they start out super soft and they
only get softer over time everyone who
tries bowline branch loves them that's
why
you can go check freeze on they have
thousands of five-star reviews so
believe the people listen to what the
people have to tell you the sheets are
even loved by three US presidents they
want you to love your your purchase to
so they'll offer you a no risk 30-day
trial and free shipping but you know
it's it's not gonna better because
you're not gonna want to send these
things back once you sleep on their
sheets you aren't going to want to sleep
on anything else so to get you started
right now my listeners get $50 off your
first set of sheets at bol and branch
dot-com promo code meant go to Boleyn
branch comm today for $50 off your first
set of sheets that's bowl beat oh ll and
branch com promo code man Boleyn branch
comm promo code mint alright so we've
covered the conspiracy angle of this and
that is a yes it is a conspiracy theory
but it's a perfectly reasonable one the
other possibility this is now and this
is according to the most boring
possibility law or theorem whatever you
want to call it which is a law that I
just made up and this law states that
the answer to every mystery is always
the most boring possible answer if
you're trying to explain something and
you survey five different possibilities
at for answers or 50 different possible
answers the answer is going to be the
most boring of the five or the 50 and
that's how you can figure it out just
which one is the most boring and the
most mundane okay that's going to be the
answer this is basically Occam's razor
is what I'm talking about here a version
of that and the most boring mundane
possibility here is that he really
killed himself and he wasn't able to do
it by government incompetence murder is
a very real possibility but I think the
most likely explanation is that plain
old government incompetence is to blame
that's that's the most likely
explanation it's not hard to see why
Epstein would want to kill himself he
lived his life of luxury now he's facing
the rest of his life you know you know
eight-foot-wide
cell and so his desire
to kill himself isn't surprising what's
surprising is that he was able to do it
but and in order for him to be enabled
to do it there would need to be a lot of
incompetence in enormous amount of
incompetence not just your average
amount of government bureaucratic
incompetence but but like severe stage
for incompetence because you've got the
most important inmate in the whole
federal prison system arguably he has
information on a vast pedophilia network
that spans the globe implicating
hundreds of powerful people you know he
wants to kill himself you know other
people would probably want to kill him
and and so all you need to do to prevent
that is watch him and he's not going
anywhere it's not like you're trailing
him or something in a car right he's
just he's sitting in a cell for 23 hours
a day all you have to do is watch him
and you can use cameras to to do it
yet they they couldn't do that that is
extraordinary incompetence but is it
easy to believe that our government
would be that in common it would be so
extraordinary incompetent they could
somehow botch this yeah it's easy to
believe our government is certainly
capable of that level of incompetence
and and that's you know that this is one
of the reasons why I usually reject a
lot of conspiracy theories about how the
government staged the moon landing or
plan 9/11 or whatever well because most
of time there's no evidence for it and
in fact all of the evidence goes the
other direction so that's one reason not
to believe those kinds of conspiracies
but also if you understand how our
government works it's just it's
impossible to believe that they could
pull off a vast far-reaching conspiracy
with and everybody remains silent
everyone cooperates like staging a moon
landing for instance if you think about
how many people in government would have
to be involved in that
we'd have to cool
operate and we're and and stay on task
and remain quiet about it keep it a
secret it's just it's there's no way
there's no way our government could ever
do that it's it's not gonna happen again
you really give them too much credit I
almost would like it would almost be
more impressive actually that's the
thing it would be more impressive if our
government pulled off a fake moon
landing then if they actually just went
to the moon actually going to the moon
would be so much easier than faking it
so which kind of goes back to an Occam's
razor type of thing so you've got to
keep the incompetence in mind it is it
is perfectly easy to believe that they
just botched this yeah somehow they
managed to pulling pulling you know a
defeat from the jaws of victory type of
thing could it easily been that but
whether it was incompetence or a
conspiracy or whatever it was or you
know a combination of them because there
is that there is a possible combination
sort of thing where Epstein did kill
himself but the prison guards looked the
other way
either because they just wanted to
because they hate him or because they
were paid off or whatever again these
are just possibilities who knows of all
whatever but whatever it is whatever the
explanation is and and as I said I don't
think we're ever going to find out but
so whatever it is it's always going to
be speculative and theoretical well
whatever it is the most depressing thing
is that it just goes to show once again
that the elites in this country are
above the law a lot of powerful people
are probably going to escape prosecution
now like they always do it was it was
always almost too good to believe not
that this pedophilia network existed but
that they were actually going to take
him down you think okay they got they
got a guy like Epstein
how often do you arrest someone like
that and you think are they finally now
gonna be able to take down some of these
powerful scumbags for once well no
apparently not and they these people
maintain their untouchability both
through active efforts on their part and
also by exploiting and relying on the
incompetence of government so whatever
the explanation is it's more of the same
and we tell ourselves this story in this
country about we the people and the
people have the power right that's the
story we tell ourselves that's the
that's the myth that's the great
American myth and it is a myth because
in the end in the end here you are I if
we commit a crime it doesn't matter what
the crime is it could be a crime way way
way less severe than what these people
with Epstein we're doing but you where I
commit a crime we're going to jail
but if you're you know a billionaire if
you're a well-connected
it really doesn't matter what you do and
this isn't just America it's been this
way across the world it's been this way
since the dawn of time it's it's been
this way everywhere all the time the
difference is we like to think it's
different here like we've us we've set
up a system that is impervious to that
but it's not I think it's I still think
it's the best possible system of all of
the of all of the bad options it's the
best one but this fact remains the same
that not everybody is subject to the law
and you know it's that
recognition that we all have about the
gist inherent unfairness of of the
system that's what leads a lot of people
to come up with these conspiracy even
that even the conspiracy theories that
are crazy and stupid even those I think
there are otherwise intelligent people
who buy into some of those even though
they should know better
there are otherwise intelligent able to
buy into those because they have so
little faith in the government and we
all have Sullivan that's why you know
you hear Epstein died and immediately
almost everyone thought the same thing
because we just have so little faith in
our system all right
so apparently moving on here the this
past week was the fifth anniversary of
Ferguson
you may remember Ferguson leftist rioted
and the media encouraged the riots over
a false narrative after a thug who
robbed a convenience store tried to kill
a cop and was it was shot in
self-defense
you remember that I'm sure well some
prominent Democrat presidential
candidates decided to observe this
solemn anniversary by blatantly lying
about it what else is new repeating
debunked claims and stirring up racial
hatred let me read a couple of these
these statements put out on Twitter by
Kamala Harris and Elizabeth Warren kamil
era said Michael Browns murder forever
changed Ferguson and America his tragic
death sparked a desperately needed
conversation and a nationwide movement
we must fight for stronger
accountability and racial racial equity
in our justice system and Elizabeth
Warren says five years ago Michael Brown
was murdered by a white police officer
in Ferguson Missouri
Michael was unarmed yet he was shot six
times I stand with activists and
organizers who continue to fight for
justice for Michael we must confront
systemic racism and police violence
head-on this is what what both of these
women have done here I know we're used
to it now but it's it would be difficult
to overstate just how dis
and cynical and despicable those
statements are that I just read calling
it a murder not just that but also
libelous if I was what was the officer's
name Darren Darren Wilson if I was
officer Wilson I'd be suing both of
these people this is this is this is
slanderous they both know okay I tell
you right now Elizabeth Warren and
Camilla Harris unlike maybe some of
their stupid followers these women
themselves they're smart enough to know
and they're plugged in and they know
that what they just said was a lie he
was not murdered and that and that fact
has been established beyond any
reasonable doubt there have been
multiple investigations on this state
and federal level under the Obama
administration and Eric Holder that
determined that this was not murder this
was not racism this was not a hate crime
this was not murder the grand jury
investigation determined that an
investigation by the DOJ once again the
DOJ under Eric Holder and Obama
investigated this and even they now they
would have loved to find a reason to say
that this was a hate crime this was they
wouldn't they would have they were
hoping they were begging to find that
evidence and even they couldn't find it
because all of the evidence went to
vindicate Darren Wilson let's go over
the facts again and this is just off the
top of my head because you know I
remember this and so I know that these
two people remember it Michael Brown and
his friend went to a convenience store
and robbed the place for no reason just
for fun it was a strong-arm robbery
they're on video they Michael Brown
grabbed as the store clerk by the shirt
collar or the neck shoves him to the
side assaults him walks out after
stealing whatever he stole some some
minor thing again there was no even
reason to do it it they were just
looking to to uh to be thugs they were
just looking to to bully this guy
and then they stroll out of there and
officer Wilson tries to stop them
at which point as officer Wilson's
trying to get out of his car he is
basically shoved back into the car the
door is slam shut
Michael Brown attacks officer Wilson
while Wilson still in the car
starts attacking him hitting him tries
to reach for the gun the gun goes off he
runs away officer Wilson Wilson tells
him to stop he stops and starts charging
at officer Wilson and even after even
after he's hit a couple times as officer
Wilson's shooting at him in self-defense
he still keeps charging that finally he
takes a shot to the head and he dies
that's what happened and that's not my
version okay that's not it's not even
really a theory of the crime which which
wasn't a crime that's that is what
happened that is again that's the result
of two different investigations on the
state and local law or the federal and
local level that is corroborated by
eyewitness testimony and forensic and
physical evidence you know they've got
the gun residue they've got DNA evidence
they've got witnesses all of that all
together confirms and establishes this
version of events that Michael Brown was
the aggressor that he was trying to but
when you're trying to take a gun from a
cop that's you're trying to kill him he
is he is certainly every right to assume
in that case that you want to kill him
and so he is going to use whatever force
necessary to stop that just like anyone
else would so officer Wilson was in a
fight for his life against this person
Michael Brown's death it's not a tragedy
actually it's it's a it's a travesty in
the sense that he threw his own life
away but this was a Crim this was a
violent criminal who
who brought about his own demise so no
that's not some sort of national tragedy
where we all go into mourning that this
guy died
that's his fault this was a violent
dangerous person who went out of his way
I mean he's going out of his way that
it's like he woke up that day and said
you know what I'm just gonna be violent
and cause trouble whoever I see that's
what I'm gonna do today well you know
what when you wake up in the morning and
that's your intention you might end up
dead that's and and I'm sorry I'm not
gonna not gonna go to sleep at night
crying over it the saddest thing about
the Ferguson case was not what happened
to Michael Brown who again was the
aggressor was trying to kill someone and
was rightly killed in the process and it
is totally 100% his fault
the most tragic thing is that the
saddest thing is what happened to
officer Wilson his a life was destroyed
over this Harris and Elizabeth Warren
both know everything that I'm saying
right now they know that in fact there
was a tweet that I found from Elizabeth
Warren back five five four four five
years ago whenever it was saying that
you know she's grateful that the DOJ is
investigating the Ferguson case because
she wants to get straight answers well
then guess what they investigated and
they came up with straight answers and
they released their report and they said
yep look we've looked at the forensics
we've talked to the witnesses and and
yeah this was not this was not murder
that was the straight answer well I
guess apparently Elizabeth Warren she
didn't like the straight answers that
she got what an absolute fraud these
people are I mean what manipulative
disgraceful despicable frauds these
people are they are not saying this in a
vacuum you know they they know what the
atmosphere is they know about the racial
tensions in this country and they would
throw that in this is like it's like
it's like throwing a stick of dynamite
into a you know just opening the door
and just throwing in dynamite not
knowing who's in there
hey whatever absolutely disgusting
and by the way as far as the witnesses
go there were witnesses that whose
testimony lined up completely with the
forensic evidence and those are
witnesses who you know are reliable and
there were also witnesses who originally
said that they these were the ones who
came up with the hands up don't shoot
thing which is a total lie it didn't
happen it didn't have the people who
invented that and it was invented they
recanted it and admitted that they lied
so the original few witnesses who
started this whole thing by claiming by
making up this whole myth mythological
scenario that never really happened they
recanted and somehow the media missed
this where they said they didn't make
that didn't happen all right let's go to
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com this is from
lorenz says Matt Epstein wasn't
protected by the government because the
government killed him he had information
on high-ranking government officials
that's why they arranged his murder well
you see Lawrence see this this is I
think this is how you differentiate
between a sort of reasonable theory
which may be a conspiracy and the kind
of unreasonable and reckless conspiracy
theorist stuff but where I think you're
more on the unreasonable and reckless
because what you're doing here is you're
just stating as fact we you as far you
have no information I mean if you have
information then talk to the FBI or talk
to somebody don't just email me about it
but see this is what this this is where
conspiracy theorists do annoy me where
they just say they just state like this
is what happened yep 9/11 was an inside
job I know it I just do yeah I know
that's this is this is it this is the
thing you can't say that so I think we
do have to be careful there just stating
when we don't know what happened you
can't just come up with your own version
and just say that it that's how it
happened you've no evidence what we have
here are a bunch of gaps in the official
story and there are a lot of gaps I
fully admit that and so you can come up
with theories you can come up with
possibilities of how we might fill in
those gaps but the whatever possibility
you come up with in your head the
existence of the gap does not in itself
prove your theory because there are a
million other other possibilities this
is from a Portis I am a 19 year old
conservative man and I listened to your
podcast every day I want to get married
early around 23 24 but my family is more
liberal and tells me that I am insane so
that's nice of them I also say that I
don't want to live with my girlfriend
and remain celibate until marriage I
assume you mean you want to remain
celibate you don't want to live with
your girlfriend anyone what are some
good arguments that can be made for not
sleeping with your girlfriend until
marriage and also not to live together
as well people seem to dismiss these
ideas way too quickly in my opinion in
ridicule others who want or try to live
up to these standards well of Portus if
that's your real name
I think the first argument should
present in favor of this choice of yours
is that it's your life and this is how
you want to live liberals are if your
family are liberals liberals are
supposed to respect that argument I mean
that's really the only argument they
respect it's the only argument they ever
make for anything so you should be able
to say you know I don't care if you if
you agree this this is what I want to do
they should respect that aside from that
I think there are a lot of really good
logical practical reasons not to live
together before marriage and you know
you don't even need to invoke morality
or bring the Bible into it I've written
about this at length elsewhere but just
to be very brief here first of all
despite common claims a marriage is not
something you can try out or try on the
thing that defines a marriage that makes
it a marriage is not your physical
proximity to the other person
that's part of it that's a feature but
the defining aspect of marriage is the
bond the union the commitment that you
make to each other therefore by
definition you can't try out a
commitment it's you're either committed
or you're not
there's no way let's see what it's like
if we're committed to each other because
if that's what you're doing then that's
not by definition that's not a
commitment that is that's a preliminary
sort of investigation so you're either
committed or you're not also I find that
people who live together before marriage
tend to be looking for the wrong things
what you want in your marriage is
someone who you love who you trust who
you respect very important in fact I
would underscore that ten times
underlined at 10 times and encircle it
because respect and America on both from
both the husband and wife is is so
important and I think what you find in a
lot of marriages that fall apart
it's that both spouses just stop
respecting each other and if you don't
respect your spouse anymore it your
marriage is on life support your
marriage is doomed really if you don't
because it's very hard if you don't
respect someone it's it's very hard to
conjure respect and it's very hard to
remain married to someone you don't
respect I would imagine so respect is
really important so you have that you
have love trust respect and then also I
think you need to share common goals and
and values you don't have to have
everything in common and that's sort of
my point here but just on a really basic
level I think you have to have some
there has to be some commonality if you
have all of those pieces then you're
golden
maybe not golden now you're still gonna
have struggles in marriage can still be
difficult at times and so you're still
gonna have to work through it but that's
all you need to take the plunge and you
can know
all of that about someone you can figure
all of that out I really believe you can
figure that out if you're an adult now
you know if you're 14 years old dating a
you know your girlfriend who's your
fellow sophomore in high school then
it's a different story but if you're an
adult dating someone everything I just
mentioned I think you can figure that
out in like three weeks it really
doesn't take much time of getting to
know someone and talking to someone not
saying you should get married after
three weeks but I think it's I I really
believe it if this was the case for me
and you talk to a lot of people who've
been married a while a lot of them are
gonna tell you that yeah I you know I
knew within weeks this isn't love at
first sight love at first sight of
course is doesn't exist either because
there's no way just by look I mean
literally at first sight I remember the
first time that I saw my now wife when I
was meeting her up for our first you
know date and I remember that seeing her
and I was attracted to her but when you
fir guy you first see a woman your first
thoughts gonna be like oh wow she's hot
but but that's not love is you can't
know anything else about them just by
looking at them but I think very quickly
you can get to know them and once you
know that then then that's all you need
to know living with them only is gonna
tell you about lesser peripheral things
like their habits they're annoying
quirks and so on but everybody has
habits and quirks and you shouldn't need
to know what those are before you get
married because if you do if you're
saying well I got to know all that stuff
too before I get married then you're
never gonna marry anyone because
everybody has stuff like that so I think
cohabitation emphasizes the wrong things
if you say I got to live with someone
for two years before I marry them I
think you got to ask yourself like what
is it about them you're trying to find
out that you don't already know finally
I think there's something something to
be said a lot to be said I think for the
unknown in getting married the
excitement the risk I think when you
live together for you know six years and
then you get married you lose almost all
of that excitement that that feeling
that you're
least striking out starting a new phase
of life together I think especially in
the beginning that's so important to
have that common feeling and that sense
it's a little scary but I think it's
important to have it if you if you've
already been living together for six
seven years and then you get married
then your first day of marriage feels
just like a normal Tuesday it doesn't
doesn't it doesn't really it's because
it's just basically the same thing
you've been doing all along nothing's
really changed in terms of your everyday
lifestyle so I think all of those
reasons are good reasons to not live
together before marriage let's see one
mores from Katie says hi Matt you asked
for disturbing movies we wish we could
unsee mine is definitely Pulp Fiction
the scene in quotes the scene in that
movie is etched forever in my memory and
I know what scene you're talking about
well we all know the scene in Pulp
Fiction yeah we were talking about this
on Twitter a few days ago I was I don't
remember how it came up but I asked
what's a movie that you've seen that was
so disturbing horrifying depressing that
you wish you could unsee it like you
actively wish that you could unsee you
could erase it from your memory a movie
that that you feel like changed you for
the worse and you'll never be the same
because you saw it and that that
question on Twitter got like 5,000
responses from people and I think it
backfired because III read through not
all of the responses but I read through
some of the thread and I actually found
that I was intrigued by a lot of the
movies people were mentioning they said
I watched this movie never have watched
this movie yeah you'd never watch it
you'll never be the same and now I'm
thinking and now I got to kind of watch
that movie I'm just so curious I got to
watch it so I feel like I'm gonna
traumatize myself now even more but yeah
pulp fiction I actually like pulp
fiction I don't know why I like pulp
fiction it you know if you described
Pulp Fiction Pulp Fiction to someone
who's who hasn't seen it it wouldn't
sound like a good movie and maybe it's
not but there is something I think
engage not about that that particular
scene I agree is disturbing but aside
from that I think it's a interesting
movie but I do
the movie that I that I nominated as a
movie that I wish I could unsee is a
movie called I'm hesitant to tell you
because I don't want you to go watch it
I of curiosity buts a movie called funny
games if anyone ever suggests that you
watch funny games don't watch it yeah
that's one that I it's just a vile
disgusting movie that shouldn't exist
and I watched it years ago and I still
think about it frequently and and
especially now that I have kids for
reasons that I won't go into based on
what's in that movie and I wish I could
unsee it the thing is there's a when I
was younger I used to have a pretty high
tolerance for disturbing and grotesque
movies and as I've gotten older though
and talking to some people as we were
discussing this on Twitter there are a
lot of people have gone through a
similar thing where for some reason when
you're younger you kind of you know
you're you're more into watching those
kind of kinds of movies and it doesn't
bother you as much but as you get older
you just see how absurd that is like if
I'm gonna go watch a movie and I'm not
saying that every movie I watch has to
be happy-go-lucky you know tearjerker
happy ending I'm not saying that at all
but the experience of being viscerally
disturbed right why would I go seek out
that experience that's another reason
why I don't really watch horror movies
anymore
because why like what's why would you
want to feel that way to feel horrified
terrified disturbed it's not an
enjoyable sensation and there's in there
are some and maybe this is why as you
get older you have less of an appetite
bored because you see more of the world
and you realize that there are so many
disturbing and horrifying things
actually happening in the world there's
no reason why I have to go seek out fake
versions of it to I can just turn on the
news if I want to be disturbed
but if I'm going to watch something
fictional then I want them to be a
little bit more to it there could be
disturbing elements of it but I don't
want that to be the whole point so yeah
it's a that's an interesting but if you
have your own nominations you can email
those movies that you wish you could
unsee alright
we will we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching god speed if you
prefer facts over feelings if you aren't
offended by the brutal truth if you can
still laugh at the nuttiness filling our
national news cycle well tune on into
the ben shapiro show where you'll get a
whole lot of that and much more we'll
see you there